I understand you did stand up recently
in Naples Florida yeah and then you
tweeted about it and I wanted I wanted
to discuss it because I imagine you have
a very specific kind of act and people
love you but then it's probably not for
everybody right oh yeah it's not for
everybody and Naples is filled with the
oldest people I've ever seen there was a
man sitting in the front row who is so
old he looked like Anna Nicole Smith's
ex-husband after he died he is the
oldest man I've ever seen right I was
like oh my gosh so you're in the wrong
place but then I was like I'm not
changing my act for you so then I did
all of my material to him which he
didn't like very much he was like why
why are you here about my body in your
last moment I did I did this like radio
show and this girl BAPS I think it's
like the Wild Bunch I don't know there's
so many radio one of those shock jock
shows yeah but one of the girls gave me
a giant dildo as a gift as a joke yeah
as a gift I like them I have
I said it's a joke and you but you
appreciated the gift no I love penises I
have a penis earring in my ear because I
just love them so much but anyway she oh
I wasn't imagining things a lot of
thought I was seeing that when it wasn't
there no I was questioning things I see
penises everywhere anywho so so she gave
me this giant dildo as a present and I
couldn't fit it into my luggage that's
it's that big it was like two feet tall
it was huge and I was like I'm just
gonna leave it in the rental car so I
get to budget rental car and I put it in
the backseat and as I was getting out
the guy looked in looked at me looked at
it and then we had an understanding that
I was leaving a present and then I
walked away and I heard them laugh so
hard yeah
and it brought me joy and then I was
like maybe this is my new thing I become
like the dildo fairy yeah
you realize someone someday if they
leave in the back of the car is going to
use not know what it isn't use it for
the wrong thing there's ice on the
windshield why is everyone looking at me
you